hahaha
hahaha
hit the deck
let's get ready for town
wake up chance
the night Hospital corpsman gets the up
patients on their way to the Head
clean urinals are passed around to the
bed patients
whether a Shore or a float each patient
must be supplied with gear for washing
up and cleaning his teeth
face and kidney basins are distributed
and the corpsman assists those patients
unable to take care of themselves
try a Butch ah say when do we listen to
the guy you must be feeling better I do
now let's get started
if a patient comes to your ward without
a toothbrush or other toilet gear you
can buy one for him at chips or the Red
Cross
Crawford care of the mouth makes your
patients feel better look better age
digestion and lessens the possibility of
infection
the help of the up patients the ward is
police basins picked up washed and
sterilized and everything made Ship
Shape before the new watch takes over
they are informed about changes in the
ward census and told about any patient
whose condition has altered during the
night
the night watch on his way off duty will
leave all urine and other specimens at
the laboratory for examination
meantime some men are taking
temperatures in the war another man is
sent to the ward Galley to set up
breakfast trays
there's more to setting up a tray than
just putting the mess gear on it a
napkin makes it more attractive and if
you've ever been safe you know how much
you appreciate a neat attractive
complete trade
by the time the steam table arrived the
trays are all set up and ready to go
cold things and staple groceries are on
the bottom which is not heated
they are taken out first and put up on
the trays
hot food kept hot in the containers up
above is placed on the trays less
while these preparations are underway
now let's go oh
I can't void Paradise the up patients
who were on unrestricted diet are sent
to the mess hall the rest of the
patients in the ward are in two classes
those who can feed themselves and those
who cannot
take out the trays carefully to avoid
spilling and check the roster to be sure
the patient is getting the prescribed
diet
most of them will be able to help
themselves
so get the trays for those men out first
your name is Phillips okay
thanks Doc
oh boy that looks good
can you reach it that's fine
okay
the trays for the patients who need
personal attention are served less
no one enjoys having to be fed but it
can be a lot more pleasant than you'd
think
don't hurry him give him bites of
everything on the tray
and here's a real chance to get
acquainted shoot the breed let him know
that you enjoy talking to him and have
plenty of time to feed it
well this patient is getting his
breakfast let's have a look at other
kinds of Trades
most patients eat the regular child
kind and quantity of food here doesn't
vary much from the regular mess
a soft diet is composed of easily
digested Foods usually given to those
with slightly elevated temperatures for
those whose appetites are below normal
liquid diets may be ordered for patients
who are quite ill or who cannot digest
solid food liquids of course are more
easily digested than solid
for diabetic patients
the diet must be carefully weighed if he
has received insulin and he doesn't eat
all his food
he may go into insulin shock
the medical officer must be informed if
the diabetic patient doesn't eat his
diet exactly as given to it
the patient who was on an ulcer diet has
milk and cream at frequent intervals
his diet is just as important as his
medication
it is essential that each patient gets
the diet prescribed for him by the
medical officer
the wrong food may make him quite ill
and may even endanger his life
when all the patients have been fed it's
time to collect the trays
the up patients back from child should
lend a hand
with as little noise and confusion as
possible the ward is squared away and
the dirty dishes are returned to the
main Galley to be washed and sterilized
morning care starts the daily routine in
any Ward or sick day with the help of
the up patients and your own cheerful
attitude you've created a feeling of
normal well-being which is good medicine
for any sailor